so now that Pokemon go has penetrated
the barrier between fiction and reality
it's rich mythology is making its way
into the real world but some of these
stories are even stranger than fiction
the apps popularity has opened up a
wellspring of misinformation about
events surrounding the hunt for
augmented reality Pocket Monsters here
are a few of the more bizarre hoaxes and
why they're absolutely not true and why
some actually are sibling stabbing no a
Florida kid named Timmy did not stab his
younger brother to death after a
misunderstanding about deleted Pokemon
while the unchecked story spread like
chlamydia on social media sites many
readers failed to realize that the fake
story originated from cartel press a
website which specializes in
intentionally fake news while many of
their headlines are obviously satirical
such as zoo claims gorillas had ties to
Isis the story of young murderous Timmy
offered no humor and it's retelling even
if you ignore the completely fake nature
of the site there are absolutely no
incidents reported in Jacksonville
similar to this event additionally you
don't even really delete your Pokemon
you just trade them in for delicious
candies get with it new you'll begin to
notice that cartel presses a trend here
you will never find a more wretched hive
of scum and villainy the 500 million
dollar lawsuit another story the traces
back to cartel press is the tale of
Charlie who wandered into the street
while playing Pokemon Go was hit by a
car and is now suing app makers Niantic
for 500 million dollars while the post
language is much more obviously a parody
of the frivolous litigation trend
readers were once again fooled to date
Niantic has not been the subject of any
pokemon girl related injury lawsuits
however Niantic spree vias gps-based
game ingress is related to at least two
reported deaths a gamer in Dublin fell
off a pier in 2016 while playing the
game another player wandered into
traffic and was hit by a bus and Rio de
Janeiro in 2014 vice interviewed cartel
press owner Pablo Reyes who is only
reasoning for spreading paranoia was
this people always expect something
anyways so if you're right about it
beforehand it's like you predicted it
psychic-type pokémon look out you've got
some competition bad neighborhood
because the bogus news from the onion
wannabe never ends we can also confirm
that Marcus Jackson did not get stabbed
during his Pokemon adventures because he
and we quote didn't
realize he had stepped into what is know
as a bad neighborhood also from cartel
press and therefore inherently false the
rumor of the highway Pikachu hundred
card pileup and Isis taking credit for
Pokemon goes login issues true however
is the remarkably similar story of
Michael Baker who was stabbed while
playing in Forest Grove Oregon the
player initially refused treatment for
his injuries so that he could continue
playing but later sought medical
attention according to an interview with
catch you two News I'm just gonna keep
catching well you know that's that's
foolish that's gonna happen no
trespassing
another fake news site reported that a
kid named our third is be was shot when
he entered the house of an aging widow
in order to catch a wild Pokemon while
the national report is another veiled
satire site many readers believe that
the story was completely real based on
comments left on the page there have
been no confirmed reports of Breaking
and Entering in order to catch imaginary
monsters primarily due to the fact that
you simply don't need to be that close
to a Pokemon to be able to capture it
based on the game's geolocation you can
usually catch any Pokemon that happens
to pop up within the borders of a
building without actually entering it
and now you know Simpsons did it while
The Simpsons has predicted plenty of
things internet hoaxes often give the
show more credit than it deserves
despite popular opinion the show did not
predict Donald Trump's campaign
announcement nor did it anticipate the
creation of Pokemon Joe and a currently
popular meme a four fingered yell hand
points in an empty corner wall
smartphone on the other hand displays a
Pikachu efforts have been made to make
this truly look like an older screen cap
from the show but it's all photoshop
folks you can see the original clip in
the episode of how I spent my summer
vacation but it's just like you or me or
Jesus over there the inevitable fee if
you want to send someone into a panic
tell them that they have to pay for a
once free service like the hundreds of
Facebook fee scares that preceded them
the Pokemon go fee rumors are false
seeing an opportunity to ride the wave
of a game scammers begin sending out
emails claiming that Pokemon go would
soon cost $12.99 per month to play
mostly so Niantic could beef up their
straining servers and apparently augment
the fortune already being spent in the
app shop Niantic has not announced a fee
nor do they have any plans to which has
been confirmed by the verge scammers
however have been using these fake
announcements to collect users personal
information don't fall for it
land down under and no Australian police
are not targeting Pokemon go players
despite a popular image that's been
circulating online well the image does
come from a real sign in Australia it's
also been the subject of countless
manipulations over the years there's no
reason for police officers to target
users of an app about imaginary animal
poaching they almost definitely have
bigger problems to worry about no that's
a not the murder witness according to
initial accounts an uber driver named
Alex Ramirez was streaming his Pokemon
go adventures between stops and
witnessed a body being tossed out of a
car oh my god huh oh my god hold Oh God
this guy just killed this chawl only
this guy just killed it oh my god oh my
god I just wasn't it up murdered he
subsequently called 911 of the body and
reported being followed by the murderers
all before getting fired by uber the
video was convincing enough that a few
top YouTube hosts two bunkers fell for
it but none actually bothered to verify
their sources
Gizmodo reports that calls to the local
police revealed that there were no
bodies found there any murders matching
that description calls to uber also
revealed that they hadn't fired anyone
over a Pokemon incident only temporarily
suspended a driver after rider
complaints this was because Ramirez was
playing while driving at high speeds
which is obvious on his channel GoFundMe
quickly pulled the page set up to help
Ramirez since it was put up under false
pretenses and the whole thing was
revealed to be a huge publicity stunt
and possibly a serious case of fraud
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos at
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Pokemon go
hoaxes you fell for
you